on est en pleine répétition ici au
collège du val de vire de maintenant
hurlé de joie sur notre chan s'est tiré
des orestie d'eschyle trois tragédies
grecques qu anthony poupard a réécrit
mise en scène pour le festival à dos de
vire
le mariage forcé j'ai un quotidien
tâches ménagères des silences
perpétuelle voilà notre avenir c'est le
calendrier
voyez me voyez mes serres voyez lui
tendre la main tremblante ce qui
réduirait leurs épouses de leurs frères
en temps témoin leur demande et sur les
murs les méfaits ok rachel c'est bien
lâche pas trop les chevaux quoi tu vois
la puissance vocale c'est très bien
l'autorité tout ça c'est très bien mais
maintenant il faut que tu y ait plus de
dextérité dans la mâchoire et coule
coule moins vite
vous aviez déjà fait du théâtre avant
non jamais jamais jamais jamais et alors
bah c'est une bonne expliqué une super
belle expérience je crois que c'est
vraiment la meilleure expérience pour
l'instant de ma vie pour l'instant quoi
se travailler avec des acteurs pourquoi
pourquoi qu'est ce qui était bien qu'est
ce que tu as le plus aimé ba2
de jouer quelqu'un qui a vécu des choses
pareilles pour la reine de 3 quand même
c'est quelque chose que sa fin le rôle
que j'ai tout sa fin même le
commencement temps avec tout le monde
quoi ses dires est une petite famille
quoi mais c'est bien puisque mythologie
déjà ça m'intéresse personnellement que
la pièce allait bien à jouer elle écoule
les écoles brûlées les temps de
décrocher le spectacle dure 1h30 en
extérieur dans la cour du collège sur
scène il y a une cinquantaine d'élèves
des 3e et des 6e une danseuse un
créateur sonore est maintenant hurlé de
joie sur notre chan est une création du
festival à d'hôtes du préau de ville
le problème c'est vieux ménélas y est
que price et 3 ya eu notre problème à
nous vieux citoyens d'argos c'est qu'un
gars mais non le frère de ménélas
humilié et qu'il est roi d'argos et tout
ça fait que son orgueil nationaliste l'a
conduit jusqu'à l'hôtel où deux chemins
il a tranché le corps de sa fille
interstices numéro 2 hier soir nous
étions sur le dôme avec cette exposition
dans tout à fait originale et
aujourd'hui nous allons aller au château
découvrir d'autres dispositifs 1 qui se
trouve à l'extérieur dans le devant la
salle des remparts qui marche avec le
vent qui génère du son aussi et qui est
due à qui alors nous avons une pièce de
marco brodeur theory strijbos cio veine
molnar qui viennent des pays bas et puis
également avoir en l'église saint
sauveur des trucs qui tourne comme on
dirait
s'appelle par sec c'est très beau très
étonnant
est ce que ce sont des artistes qui
viennent d'écoles particulière pour
faire ses oeuvres c'est très souvent des
gens qu'on fait des écoles d'art mais
aussi pour une pratique de dunes puis
numérique de l'informatique de la
programmation mais qui reste toujours
des plasticiens dont qui travaillent la
forme l'objet le rapport aux sons à
l'espace donc ces mélanges là qui nous
nous intéresse pour les aller les
chercher dans les interstices de la
création
là où ça bouge nous sommes avec helena
noguerra pour cette pièce verra c'est un
beau rôle c'est pas un seul rôle en fait
non on joue enfin moi je joue quatre
rôles nous on joue tous plusieurs rôles
sauf karin viard karin viard joue verra
qui est le personnage principal acquis
toutes ces choses vont arriver au
nouveau tout rond
on sert de de tournon elle commence à
les saluer si on enlève les allées trop
bien sûr et c'est pas tout j'ai une
excellente helena noguerra toujours été
admiratif du travail de marcial di fonzo
bo l'acteur metteur en scène est
aujourd'hui directeur de la comédie de
caen d'abord je les ai découverts sur
dvd
et puis j'ai vu une pièce dans laquelle
joue et karine et je les ai attendus à
la sortie des artistes et puis je leur
ai dit que j'aimais beaucoup ce qu'ils
faisaient
ils m'ont invité à boire un verre mais
j'ai refusé je voyais pas trop ce que je
pouvais dire et puis petit à petit voilà
je suis retourné le voir je suis amené
des choses que j'écrivais j'ai établi un
contact
et puis quelques années après il m'a il
m'a offert donc pas un rôle mais déjà
plusieurs rôles dans une femme avec
catherine hiégel et donc c'est la
deuxième collaboration dont aujourd'hui
vous êtes senti bien pendant nouveau
travail ici j'adore déjà d'abord j'adore
la normandie ça c'est un vieux fantasme
je pense toujours que je vais m'acheter
une petite maison en normandie je ne
suis pas encore arrivé
et puis surtout marcial di fonzo bo sait
j'adore l'observer travail et j'adore
voir la création
j'aime voir comment il construit son
récit comment ils nous amènent à des
choses qu'on ne connaît pas nous comment
ils travaillent les personnages jamais
déjà karin viard sans la connaître et je
laime encore plus maintenant que je la
connais j'aime voir la somme de travail
qu'elle est capable de de prendre sur
elle comme on avait elle gère tout ça de
manière très très douce très humble et
en même temps très forte
donc oui c'est un mois un mois de
liberté
merci beaucoup merci à vous